Hi,
Dr. Peterson.
Now I'd been wanting to ask you this,
uh,
for a while now since I
started watching your lectures.
Um,
after I started reading a
Nietzsche's beyond good and evil,
I came upon a paragraph in his
chapter on scholars that really,
really bothered me and it's
actually bothers me to this day.
Uh,
he,
he talks about this kind of person,
like they were a just a mirror.
I like,
they stretched,
he said every part of their skin
basically to allow every new piece of
information that they took on and
that all they ever were was just an
instrument.
They were just a mirror on
reflecting what they had learned,
never actually having generated
anything on their own.
And it's,
it's bothered me because I feel
like in a way it sort of like,
it's,
it's impacted my identity
a lot because I don't know,
how are you supposed to create something,
you know,
so.
Okay,
well that's okay.
That,
that's a really good question.
I mean,
neat chip is often clashed
with the existentialists,
right?
And so one of the tenants
of existentialist,
there's two real tenants
of existentialism.
There's more,
but obviously we're oversimplifying,
but one is that life is a problem.
It isn't because there's
something wrong with you.
It's that life is a problem.
And so that's often contrasted
with the Friday and view,
which is that if you have a problem,
it's because something went
wrong during your development.
The existentialist said,
no,
no.
It's like life is a problem.
Make no mistake about it.
And that,
yes,
the purpose of
the purpose of scholarship is in
some sense to solve that problem.
And so for Nicha,
like he said,
all truths are bloody truths to me.
And what he meant by that was that if an
idea didn't incarnate itself in you and
transform your perceptions
and your actions,
then you were merely
possessed by the idea.
You are merely a
spokesperson for the idea.
Or You could say that
the idea possessed you.
You're a puppet for the idea.
It's not you.
It's the idea is in you and it has you.
You haven't taken the idea
and incorporated with you
and made it part of your
life.
And so there's a romanticism
that's associated with that,
right?
That's the passionate scholar.
The person for whom ideas are not merely,
they're not merely,
what would you call abstracted
representations that can
be tossed about as if
they're commodities.
They're there,
they're more like per,
they're more like personalities.
That might be another
way of thinking about it.
And so if you're,
if,
if those ideas are compelling,
then you don't
like one thing I learned a long time ago,
and I think this is probably relevant,
I know when I was a kid I liked to
argue and I like to win arguments or or,
or lose them,
although I like winning them a lot better,
but I didn't really mind so much
what the content of the argument was.
You know,
I could engage in it like a sparring match
and it was in some sense to establish
dominance,
right?
To establish intellectual dominance.
I quit doing that when I was in my mid
twenties because I thought that that was
too shallow and approach to the ideas.
They,
they're not commodities of that sort.
They're there,
they have tendrils that
reached down into the living.
That's the right way to think about it.
And so niche criticism of scholars and
he did this a lot was that they were
bloodless.
You know,
they didn't,
they were full of
performative contradictions.
That's another way of thinking about,
they'd say one thing and do another
because their intellect was completely
dissociated from their,
from their actions.
And he,
he,
he thought that was a very bad idea.
And I think that that's a good criticism.
I think it is a bad idea.
I also think it makes for an
extraordinarily boring lecturer,
you know,
cause you can tell if
you're listening to someone,
whether the idea is that you're hearing
are merely being passed through the
person as if they're being memorized,
say or whether they're part of
the dynamic core of the person.
And if they're part of the
dynamic core of the person,
then they're almost always
engaging in gripping.
And so he wasn't a fan
of bloodless scholars.
And I think that's correct because
one of the things that I see,
it's not a good idea to
have ideas possess you
unless you know what
the idea is are up to.
And lots of people are possessed by ideas
rather than possessing them and not,
what that means is they haven't taken
the ideas and integrated them into their
own being.
They haven't,
it's like an incarnation in a sense.
They have an incarnated the ideas in
embodied form and so they're incomplete,
you know,
nature also in thus spake Zarathustra
when Xero Theaster comes down the
mountain,
he sees a bunch of people gathered
around a famous individual,
I think maybe a scholar
but doesn't really matter.
And when Xero Theaster goes
and looks at the person,
only sees his little tiny
midget with the gigantic ear.
And so he's a hyper specialist,
right?
And so he has a pretty impressive year,
but he's only this big.
And that was niches,
images,
stick commentary on the danger of hyper
specialization and also on the danger of
adulation for hyper specialization.
And cause he thought about
it as a kind of deformity.
Now,
nature was a pretty harsh guy,
but,
um,
but he did address the issue
of the relationship between
intellectual knowledge
and an action because for nature,
those things are not to be
separated in some sense.
So yeah.
So maybe,
I don't know why,
maybe it bothered you,
like it's hard to say why it bothered you.
It might have bothered you because it
sort of undermine the idea of scholar.
But the other possibility,
and this isn't an accusation because
obviously I don't know anything about you,
but it might also be
that it struck a chord,
you know,
and that maybe you were doubtful or
questioning how tightly associated your
intellectual endeavor was with your
actual character and your practice.
So that's another possibility.
I mean,
that's a really good thing to think
about because generally speaking,
that integration has,
is very much lacking.
People are a lot smarter and fluid with
their ideas than they are ethical and
consistent and characterized by integrity.